hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a fantasy and romance
movie called its a boy girl thing
the film begins with Woody and Nelly
they are neighbors and former childhood
friends who go to the same high school
one night Woody plays music at a loud
volume which makes Nelly annoyed and
angry with him because Woody doesn't
want to turn the music down she gets
angry and immediately closes the window
unfortunately her clothes get stuck in
the window making Woody see Nellie's
naked body
they have very different habits Woody is
a popular varsity football player while
Nelly is a girl who loves literature but
lacks social skills they loathe each
other and are constantly in dispute when
Woody wants to go to school he is picked
up by his friend Harry while Nelly walks
to school because she missed the school
bus while walking Woody and Harry
intentionally pass a puddle of water
which made Nellie's body drenched
Nellie's appearance looked disheveled
when she arrived at the school as a
result Woody's girlfriend Brianna laughs
at her in the school hallways Woody also
pretends to apologize to her Nelly
eventually decides to ignore them in the
classroom Woody idly types obscene
things on Nellie's computer that makes a
loud noise causing all the students in
the class to laugh at her later their
class goes on a school trip to an
ancient Museum Woody and Nelly are
forced to work together on an assignment
because of it they quickly begin arguing
in front of a statue of the ancient
statue as they argue the statue quietly
casts a spell upon them at night the
spell works on their bodies causing them
to wake up in each other's bodies the
next morning when they wake up they
panic because their bodies have swapped
last night they are also very confused
with each other's habits when they
arrive at school they immediately blame
each other for the body swap but agree
to pretend to be the other person until
they can find a way to switch back at
first they seem to succeed but quickly
return to arguing when they each feel
the other is misrepresenting them in the
opposite body such as would he answering
a question oddly from the teacher later
Nelly also humiliates Woody's body in
the cafeteria by dropping his food
inevitably she has to join the football
practice because Woody is the leader of
his team however she doesn't know what
to do causing the coach to scold her for
the poor performance on the pitch
the next day it turns out that their
bodies are still swapped and have not
returned Woody sees Nelly is wearing
neat clothes making Woody's appearance
look dorky which frustrates him he is
even more frustrated after he hears
about how Nelly failed Woody's football
practice the previous day as payback
Woody dress is an inappropriate and
provocative clothing to the school the
following day he also intentionally
makes Nellie's reputation worse after
school Nelly in retaliation breaks up
with Brianna much to the disappointment
of Woody furthermore the humiliation
competition continues when Woody drives
off with a biker boy Nikki and makes
Nelly think she is going to lose her
virginity however Woody thinks that it
feels so wrong because he's a man inside
a woman's body and not completely a
woman he then decides to leave Nikki
the next morning rumors are being spread
around the school by Nikki about his
night with Nelly when she overhears
about it she gets very upset soon Woody
finds Nelly at the school quarter he
admits that he didn't actually lose
Nellie's virginity and that everyone was
simply spreading Nikki's lies
nonetheless Nellie is still let down and
so Woody decides to confront Nikki it
turns out that Woody can't fight him
because he is inside Nellie's body but
at the right time Nelly runs up and
punches Nikki in the face forcing him to
admit all his lies afterwards Woody is
worried that his football match will be
held soon suddenly they realize that
before their bodies were swapped they
argued in front of an ancient statue
which turns out to be an ancient Aztec
on tescatley polka Nelly and Woody reach
a truce and they immediately head down
to the museum
sadly they fail to return to their
original bodies after confronting the
statue they then realized that they are
going to have to help each other in two
important upcoming events Nelly must
learn how to play football for Woody's
upcoming match and Woody must learn
about poetry and literature for Nellie's
upcoming interview later that night
Nelly is getting drunk at a party with
Harry while Woody is stuck at a slumber
party with Nellie's friends Listening to
All the gossip about himself he is also
surrounded by nail polish pajamas and
gets a bikini wax
later Woody takes care of Nelly who is
dizzy from last night's hangover after
spending so much time together they
become very fond of each other and start
to understand each other better the
night before the interview in the game
they agree to go to the school party
together as not a day
the day of the interview and match Woody
goes for the interview he initially
messes things up and is asked to leave
but he starts to talk about poetry and
rap which impresses and astonishes the
interviewer after that he goes to the
football game and watches Nelly run in
the winning touchdown in the closing
seconds a college recruiter witnesses
her good performance and wants to talk
to her later after the game they
congratulate each other for their
successes they sincerely have forgiven
each other and said similar words as
when they were arguing in front of the
ancient statue shortly after this the
spell lifts and they eventually return
to their original bodies the scene
finishes with Woody being kissed by
Brianna and Nelly going home because she
is very upset seeing it
soon Woody tries to invite Nelly to the
school party but he is stopped by her
mother who sees Woody's family as
uneducated Nelly then receives an
acceptance letter from the University
meaning that her interview which was
done by Woody in her body earlier was
successful however she is still upset
with Woody and decides not to go to the
school party meanwhile Nellie's father
has a talk with her on the porch about
Woody during which she confesses she
truly likes him and her father surprises
her with a dress and shoes for the party
on the other hand Woody and Brianna are
selected as the school king and queen as
they prepare to dance Woody suddenly
sees Nelly and both confess their love
for each other straight away in the end
they leave the school together and share
a kiss in front of their houses as their
father secretly cheers for them together
the following day Nelly tells her mother
that she is taking a year sabbatical
before attending the university and she
hops into Woody's cars that drive off
together
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching